Gripping his blade tightly, Yuta speaks up
and tells the group that he’s going to go join
the battle to help Gojo. Not pleased to hear
this as he stated he’d be the first to leave,
Kashimo sparks up his cursed energy and warns Yuta
to not interfere as its not him who’ll fight next.
Seeing his boys cursed energy
flare up, Hakari asks Yuta to
calm down & says Gojo had initially asked
them to tag in when he starts to lose the
battle or gets overwhelmed. But Yuta rebukes
staying since Sukuna's DE is now disabled,
he can help Gojo by handling
the two shikigamis with Rika.
Speaking up, Maki tells Kashimo to not forget his
overall role in this battle. If he's defeated then
some of there back up insurance will be gone. Yuta
is just like but bruh, if we just go for it now
and take this gamble and win against Sukuna,
then the insurance won't be needed at all.
Probably just eager to test his new body swapping
ability, Yuji takes Yuta's side & encourages him
to go for it. I love how this back up plan
of theirs really hasn't even been discussed,
like we know Kashimo said he’s gonna go
next. But was this spoken about beforehand
with Gojo? Yuta made it seem like they’ve all
had this chat in the days before this battle,
so im guessing there is an underlying plan
that our team does have. Anyways Anyways.
They all think that because Sukuna isn't able to
give his everything & Gojo is at his best when
he doesn't need to worry about others, this
setup they’re currently in has the highest
probability of winning. Getting slightly
bummed out with this both Yuji and Yuta
sulk after realizing that they’re probably just
going to be a hinderance if they enter. Pulling
them back to reality though, Kashimo tells them
thats not exactly true. At the end of the day,
this is Gojo's fight and it would just
be lame as hell if they interfered.
Hakari himself suspects that Sukuna might have a
Trump Card & is preserving it for later. So if the
sorcerers act to quickly and reveal their hand,
Sukuna might end up using that trap card on them.
Back inside of Shinjuku the two massive
Shikigami attack Gojo in combination,
however Gojo evades the attacks with ease &
lands his own counterattack black flash. Jumping
back its shown that Agito wasn't even fazed by
the hit and instead sends its tail to attack,
which is infact a miniature version of the great
serpent proving that this beast was probably
made up of even more Shikigami than originally
thought. Ripping off the head of the serpent tail,
Gojo watches as Mahoraga quickly pushes the
other Shikigami aside to protect it as it heals.
Pondering on this new beast some more,
Gojo thinks that Agito is most likely made
up of 'Nue', which firstly inherited
the 'Great Serpent', then the 'Mourn
Tiger' & 'Round Deer'!! Still none of that
even matters in the larger scheme of things,
since Agito isn't adapted to Limitless like
Mahoraga, Gojo plans to destroy it in one
shot. Stepping away again for one second,
another random reveal I almost missed,
but what is this Mourn Tiger. Surely thats the
10th Shikigami from the Ten Shadows technique
that we haven't seen yet? The lines across
Agito’s chest could resemble the Tigers markings,
love to know what you all think and if we’ll ever
get an explanation on this Shikigami later on.
Placing his blade on the floor,
Mahoraga flicks it at Gojo causing
a line of rubble to get thrown up into his
face. Blocking the rocks with his infinity,
Gojo then proceeds to dodge out of the way of
the Shikigami’s follow up attack. Continuing,
Dad then launches a fat head kick
that pushes the creature back.
Turning around, Gojo quickly activates his
infinity and brings the 2nd Shikigami in
closer. Having seen Agito use RCT to heal its
tail before, Gojo realizes itl be troublesome
if it also heals Sukuna during battle,
so his plan is to firstly deal with it.
Elsewhere inside of his dank shadowy world,
Sukuna starts creating a plan to not let
Gojo use his prolific hollow purple.
He knows that last time Gojo used it,
the attack was amped up to 120%,
still he was able to take it head
on with somewhat minimal damage since it
was coming from such a large distance.
However due to everything thats happened
since then, if Dad does hit him with even
a 100% hollow purple right now, then it will
be fatal. Knowing that Mahoraga wasn't showing
him everything. Sukuna speaks up and asks his
Shikigami how long its going to make him wait.
He’s not dumb and knows its no longer MEGUMI’S
SHADOW, so demands that it show him what its
got! Following those orders, Mahoraga’s wheel
spins and sends forth an ability that looks
exactly like Sukuna’s dismantle which slices
the greatest sorcerer of todays arm right off.
Not leaving his shadowy realm, Sukuna chuckles
and praises Mahoraga for its adept use of his
technique, while simultaneously a bunch of
the sorcerers all scream in pure panic. Shoko
personally knows that this isn't great timing
at all as Gojo’s healing is currently weakened.
Re-emerging from his shadows
and taking the advantage,
Sukuna punches Gojo before quickly following
up with a wicked snap kick that sends Gojo
directly into the path of Agito who’d
begun flaring up its cursed energy.
Agito proceeds to absolutely pummel
Gojo’s head with a fat right hook. However
Gojo looking completely manic looks into its eyes
while creating an orb of condensed blue and tells
Agito that for a while now it wasn't worthy enough
to be considered an opponent in this battle.
LITERALLY SCREEEEAM LIKE SSJ3
SMASHING HIS LEFT HAND DOWN, GOJO EFFORTLESSLY
THRASHES AROUND THE PATHETIC CURSE. Looking
at Sukuna and Mahoraga, he cements Agito’s
uselessness as he captures it completely within
his NEW BLUE MAXIMUM OUTPUT AND SENDS THE PATHETIC
CREATURE HURLING TOWARDS SUKUNA AND MAHORAGA.
Dodging out of the blasts way, Sukuna
can only watch as the amalgamation
of Shikigami’s is sent hurling through
Shinjuku before it’s eventually crushed
and destroyed under the pure force
of Gojo’s Maximum output technique.
41 seconds later GOJO’S PURPLE HAS ALSO RIPPED
ITS WAY THOROUGH THE BATTLEFIELD IN SHINJUKU
Well yeah this is getting absolutely insane now,
Subscribe and leave a like if you have enjoyed
what i've done with the latest Jujutsu Kaisen
Chapter and want me to cover the current stuff
going on weekly, idk if ill call em reviews
cause yeah. Bruh was I the only one thinking
that damn Gojo is hella lucky his domain can be
thrown up off one arm, or can do any technique
with just one hand. If he was in like a Hakari
situation man could’ve just cemented his defeat.
What im curious about is this mysterious purple
that apparently was sent out 41 seconds later,
will Mahoraga adapt to purple or is Gege ending
it next week cause there isn't a break. Sukuna was
getting kinda nervous over the idea of taking
a 100% Purple to the dome. BUT im questioning
if Dads even able to use a 100% purple after
also using a maximum output technique. Maybe
my understanding is slightly wrong, not that
it even matters, everyone's understandings
have been completely re-invented with this
fight. I don't expect it to end next week,
like if we saw Gojo’s arm in the final panel
its just beginning to heal now which in my eyes
just means its gonna go down to fists soon. Plus
Kashimo telling Yuta to sit tf down pussy boy,
this a 1v1 on rust is amazing. Eitherway,
subscribe if you are new around here and
leave a like if you want me to cover this
battle weekly until it ends. Obviously it
wont affect bigger vids, still gonna
be dropping fat arc videos aswell,
im just personally loving JJK rn, but for now
its been ya professional degenerate Diavolo